pour leur première visite
il leur a préparé une petite surprise
je mets train je crois que ça au rythme
de vieux disques de jazz etienne 31 ans
fait découvrir copenhague à son frère et
son père à 50 euros la journée
on peut louer ces barques à moteur sans
aucun permis
idéal pour visiter la ville et ses
canaux etienne est architecte
il s'est installé à copenhague il ya un
an et depuis il a découvert l'art de
vivre à la danoise et ses spécialités
locales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'ils ont du pain noir c'est mon
normalement il mangeait avec des
couverts tartine tellement remplie que
tu peux pas la manger à la main ont
découvert le sport ben rhodes
c'est cette tranche de pain de seigle
tartines et de pickles un mélange de
légumes vinaigrés le tout recouvert de
rosbif votre famille expérience un pique
nique improvisé sur le canal copenhague
c'est un peu la dolce vita à la mode
scandinave
[Musique]
moins connu que berlin ou amsterdam
la capitale du danemark est située au
nord de l'europe point c'est entre
l'allemagne et la suède
baignant dans les eaux de la mer
baltique copenhague cultive jalousement
son art de vivre typiquement danois avec
un million d'habitants
deux fois moins dense qu'à paris la
capitale est fier d'être qualifiés comme
la plus heureuse au monde
si les températures peuvent descendre
jusqu'à moins de 10 en hiver aux beaux
jours
envie dehors les terrasses se
remplissent et les quais se transforme
en station balnéaire sous le nez de la
reine margrethe très populaire ici et de
son mari henri de laborde de monpezat un
français copenhague c'est aussi la
capitale du design et du vélo une ville
verte écolo qu'il cultive ses espaces de
nature sauvage
on peut même y croiser un élan en
faisant son footing 8000 français ont
choisi de s'y installer comme allison
une étudiante qui profite pleinement du
modèle danois
après deux mois je pense que je me suis
dit c'est bon je pense que j'avais
repéré
nous avons aussi suivi thomas qui fait
de copenhague
chaque année en dance floor géant
[Musique]
un esprit de liberté souffle dans la
capitale en particulier dans le quartier
de christiania une enclave hippie avec
ses propres règles vont vite une
française depuis 1976 et puis je suis
tombée amoureuse de tripoli c'est ça qui
sont ces français qui ont choisi de
goûter à la ville du bonheur
[Musique]
cette capitale si souvent cité en
exemple comment petit paradis une
danoise en a fait son fond de commerce
viens on va prendre un café et la malène
reed al est la plus française des
danoises elle vit à paris
mais aujourd'hui elle est venue rendre
visite à son frère j'espère grâce à son
best seller heureux comme en danois
mme allen est devenue l'ambassadrice
d'un certain art de vivre que l'on
retrouve partout à copenhague
on appelle ça le hughes ça veut dire que
c'est le côté chaleureux simple
accessible qui dans la culture danoise
un pilier d'être ensemble de faire des
choses simples de la vie
boily café et des serait un comble à se
sentir chez soi qu'on aille sans
prétention les danois sont connus pour
leur humilité
d'ailleurs dans la rue il n'est pas rare
de croiser la famille royale qui habite
le quartier
ce sont des clients réguliers de se
'
où l'on y vend de simples aux dogues une
spécialité typiquement danoise dont
raffole même les princes
oui c'est vrai le prince joachim est un
client
et quand il était plus jeune il venait
aussi avec son fret
ratiba comme dans les cars - non c'est
incroyable c'est un pays tranquille d'un
petit pays marie la princesse elle fait
son footing tous les matins soir ici
elle a un garde du corps mais il est à
vélo 50 mètres derrière elle mais
joachim le prince il en a pas de la
simplicité et de la décontraction
copenhague est une ville où l'on peut en
bas de chez soi
pratiquer ce sport unique au monde le
kayak polo du water-polo mais en canoë
on peut même se baigner dans une eau
limpide aux bronzés en bikini en toute
liberté
une qualité de vie considérée par
beaucoup comme exceptionnelle et qui
attire de plus en plus de français
à deux pas du palais royal voici néant
le vieux port et coeur historique de la
ville
ici les bateaux à touristes en remplacer
les draps quart des vikings
allison une étudiante en informatique de
22 ans travaille sur les quais 10 heures
par semaine soit deux petites journées
mais à copenhague c'est suffisant pour
toucher le jackpot
j'annonce et hrt moi je prends les
autres allison est serveuse dans ce
restaurant typique non danois pas besoin
pour elle de connaître la langue dans ce
quartier touristique
tout le monde parle anglais
on y sert les fameuses mort brode 15
euros l'assiette radisson et payer 15
euros de l'heure auxquels s'ajoutent en
fin de mois une aide de l'état plutôt
généreuse si on travaille minimum
quarante trois heures par mois et qu'on
ait de l'union européenne on gagne 7 700
euros peu près de l'état par mois en
plus jamais entendu parler d'une telle
bourse ça me passe incroyable et ont dû
couper je me suis fait que travailler
bonjour vous avez choisi le salaire
mensuel d'alison avec l'appoint de
l'état peut monter jusqu'à 1500 euros
de quoi faire rêver un étudiant français
l'état donne beaucoup mais ils prélèvent
aussi le taux d'imposition est le même
pour tous près de 60% un record mondial
la vie au danemark et cher alors pour
alison malgré sa bourse d'étudiant dans
supplément il faut chercher des bons
plans
je n'ai d'ailleurs
tu peux les posez là aujourd'hui elle se
rend chez un coiffeur branché ambiance
punk avec des pneus en guise de repose
pieds et des bébés bande -sur mur c'est
quoi la découpe dans le dos c'est la
grande décision je refais juste faire
faire ça ça fait depuis saison que je
n'ai pas fait une foule tous âges
ensemble encore plus scène danoise
normalement une coloration ici coûte 150
euros mais alison père à moitié moins
centré sur les couleurs des déclarations
qui ont causé 50 % au danemark
la féminité rime souvent avec féminisme
ici les femmes sont considérées comme
l'égal des hommes
contrairement à la france il n'y a pas
de disparités de salaires la société
danoise et très égalitaire
j'ai l'impression d'être beaucoup plus
légal de des amis sic en france sas
assure short avec un danois un moment
donné et au bout d'un moment il dit est
ce que est ce que c'est ok si je
t'invite au restaurant jeu oui enfin
c'est toujours quelque chose de positif
m non parce que quand même on est éduqué
cette manière de ça se fait pas d'eux
d'inviter les femmes parce que c'est
perçu comme un monde d'égalité si elle
s'est faite toute belle c'est pour aller
danser car à l'autre bout de la ville
une grande fête se prépare copenhague m
sa jeunesse c'est carrément sur la place
de l'hôtel de ville qu'un festival va
donner son coup d'envoi les fans à sa
tête
thomas fleurs qu'un un franco danois de
42 ans
bon je faire j'attends le mec sait qu il
est devenu le roi de la fête au danemark
l'accord contient en fait le truc
maintenant mettre un de nos gars là là
bas aussi son festival distorsion se
propage dans toutes les rues de la ville
un concept proche de notre fête de la
musique le nettoyage des toilettes la
sécurité du dialogue avec notre ami le
maire et toutes ces choses là et donc
après on laisse les jeunes s'épanouir
dans la rue et c'est ce qui a fait le
succès extraordinaire du problème
dans quelques heures cent cinquante
mille fêtards envahiront les rues de
copenhague certains paieront d'autres
pas selon les concerts auxquels ils
veulent assister à ajouter les
subventions de la mairie et les sponsors
ce festival assure tout au long de
l'année à thomas des revenus
confortables 10000 euros par mois allez
viens on va manger
il vit avec son épouse norvégienne
golo et leurs deux enfants dans un grand
appartement du quartier le plus chic de
copenhague il ya 15 ans c'était vraiment
pas cher par rapport aux capitales
européennes c'était vraiment vraiment
sous le sous le marché moyen européen
maintenant c'est du sept 8000 euros de
mètres carrés des prix qui restent
malgré tout en dessous du marché
parisien
messieurs clame sur mes nouvelles moi
comme cbs qui met les rues de salaire je
veux mais peluche qu'elle euros mais je
vais animer peluche jardin d'enfants
non thomas a beau être le roi de la fête
il n'en reste pas moins un papa modèle
élever un enfant au danemark est
peut-être plus facile qu'ailleurs
l'état fait tout pour que les parents
puissent se passer du temps avec leurs
enfants et ce dès la naissance et non
non non non non la mère a un nom entier
de de congés et on peut partager se
croiser jusqu'à 50% avec le l'homme donc
on peut prendre six mois chacun moi j'ai
pris à la française j'ai pris quatre
jours derniers préparatifs avant le
départ
n'oublie pas je vais aller chercher à
trois heures l'entrée au plus tard
parfait salut ma chérie bhl et on met le
casque pour aller à l'école
ça se passe toujours en deux roues comme
60% des habitants de copenhague
tomas se déplace essentiellement avec ce
moyen de locomotion
des zigzags qu'aucun axe est la taille
parfaite pour faire du vélo
il ya des pistes cyclables partout et
les gens font attention c'est vraiment
une partie intégrante de la ville
depuis les années 70 tout est fait pour
encourager ce mode de transport écolo
ici les voitures sont surtaxés les vélos
ont pris toute la place
piste à deux voies
indicateur de vitesse
[Musique]
et même poubelles spéciales bicyclette
c'est ici qu'a été inventé le cargo bike
pour transporter entre autres les
enfants aujourd'hui avec ses 400 km de
réseau cyclable deux fois plus qu'à
paris copenhague se targue d'être la
première ville du vélo monde dernières
constructions en date le snake une piste
qui serpente à travers les immeubles à
l'initiative du projet frank james n
le maire de copenhague comme tous ses
concitoyens lui aussi se déplace en deux
roues ce qui pousse les gens à se rendre
dans vélo ces crânes coûte pas cher vous
faites de l'exercice vous profiter du
bonheur alors que si vous êtes assis
dans votre voiture dans les
embouteillages
vous vous énervez la bicyclette
contribuent à placer le danemark en tant
que pays le plus heureux du monde
et pour promouvoir sa ville et son
bien-être à vélo frank james n a eu une
idée si on pouvait organiser le départ
du tour de france ici au danemark ça
c'est fantastique imaginé la course
cycliste la plus renommée dont la
capitale du vélo ça montrera l'exemple
que d'autres villes deviennent aussi des
villes de vélo
la ville fait la promotion du deux roues
mais aussi ça peut paraître étonnant de
la gastronomie
à copenhague il n'y a pas que des sports
brode ou des saucisses servis à chaque
coin de rue on peut aussi très bien y
manger la ville abrite selon certaines
revues prestigieuses les meilleurs
restaurants au monde comme le nomma
quatre fois lauréat en dix ans
en plein déménagement il a depuis fermé
mais nous avons retrouvé dans le nouveau
quartier des docks un de ses anciens
chefs
c'est un ami de malines matt orlando un
américain il a depuis quatre ans ouvert
son propre établissement
un endroit où il cultive l'esprit fugue
le fameux art de vivre à la danoise mais
si tu goûtes le plus vert je vais un peu
plus secrets le restaurant a son propre
potager accessible à tous il ya plein de
gens qui viennent ici on s'installe avec
leurs bouteilles de vin ça c'est dans le
jardin
une dizaine de personnes qui sont
installés sur les tables
ce ne sont même pas des clients du
restaurant ils font juste pique nique au
jardin et vous savez je préfère vraiment
avoir un jardin rempli de gens heureux à
buvant du vin joyeusement compte avoir
un jardin tout vide mais l'autre
particularité de l'établissement qui
vient d'obtenir sa première étoile
michelin
c'est ce bûcher que la nuit tombe les
clients sort du restaurant et se
réunissent autour du feu ils discutent
entre eux et font connaissance
pour moi ça fait vraiment partie
l'esprit du restaurant est exactement la
nature elle est servie brut chez matt
orlando sur le pouce
il va composer pour malines l'un des
plats signature de son restaurant des
asperges grillé servi avec toutes les
herbes de son jardin juste assaisonner
par un filet de jus de citron de l'huile
d'algues marines et de la poudre de
piment
[Musique]
piché pouce de petits pois fenouil
requête
c'est décontracté c'est simple c'est
ces trains danois copenhague nouvelle
capitale européenne de la gastronomie
peut-être bien mais elle se distingue
déjà par son architecture des bâtiments
ultra design ondes émergé ces dernières
années comme le nouvel opéra ou la
bibliothèque municipale
surnommé le diamant noir la plupart ne
sont pas signés par des gens nouvelles
ou des philippe starck
mais par deux jeunes architectes
mon big une agence d'architecturé
mondialement connu au milieu de ces
dizaines de jeunes talents nous avons
retrouvé etienne notre guide touristique
il a eu la chance d'être recruté ici où
il travaille avec jacob son supérieur un
danois qui parle garance et un
espacement de 70%
lagence vient de décrocher la
construction du nouveau siège mondial de
google aux états unis etienne lui n'est
pas encore sur ce chantier
mais à seulement 31 ans il travaille
déjà sur un très beau projet sur la plus
belle avenue du monde au coeur de paris
les galeries lafayette c'est sûr y'a pas
je pense beaucoup d'autres bureaux qui
touchent à des problèmes si prestigieux
une expérience chez big en tout début de
carrière c'est un tremplin formidable et
pour décrocher ce job en or
etienne n'a pas fait dans le cv
traditionnel candidature c'était
de meilleures choses que j'ai vues je
pense est on est on est tous deux fois
que vous connaissez l'histoire qu'il a
envoyé une vidéo sur un cv vidéo etienne
rap ses origines sa formation et son
parcours professionnel et c'est bien lui
qui chante avec humour il interpelle
directement
bjarke ingels le jeune patron de big il
y avait quand même une voix qui a dit
mais ce qu'il faut quand les demandes de
nous envoyer quand même une cv
traditionnel où on peut voir son boulot
mais je pense qu'on a tous timéo quoi
qu'il arrive à faire ça qu'est ce qui
n'arrive pas à faire donc je pense que
pas combien de minutes après tu as eu de
réponse que
je venais quelques heures plus tard
bjarke ingels en personne le patron de
big l'envoi d'un sms
son contrat est prêt il n'a plus qu'à
venir le signer se mettre au travail
roux danemark faire confiance à la
jeunesse n'est pas une exception
c'est la règle ok des cheveux gris c'est
bien mais c'est pas un critère en soit 5
couleurs nous on regarde pas les âges on
regarde pas si on a 25 35 45 ans nous on
regarde tout ce qui tue et qu'est ce
qu'on a fait et qu'elle est surtout quel
esprit au danemark
le marché du travail est très flexible
contrairement à la france un salarié qui
démissionnent peut toucher des
allocations chômage les patrons eux
peuvent se séparer de leurs employés
sans contraintes administratives ou
financières
à ce stade de sa carrière en france le
salaire détiennent avoisinerait les 1700
euros chez bing ils gagnent le double a
été renouvelé deux fois et on a augmenté
sans cacher la demande et donc non j'ai
pas vraiment des sas et ça c'est assez
inouïe quand chance j'ai l'impression
qu'on est quand même assez chouchouter
au niveau de l'environnement de travail
on cherche vraiment à ce que les gens
soient bien on n'est pas obligé de
être habillé trop sérieux on peut
vraiment arriver à l'aise c'est pas
parce qu'on a les pieds à l'air que
qu'on est moins productif au contraire
16h30 fin de la journée
etienne est libre d'arrivée partir quand
il veut l'important c'est que le travail
soit fait il en profite cet après midi
pour rejoindre sa famille et continuer
leur exploration de la ville parmi les
sites incontournables
il ya bien sûr la petite sirène tiré du
conte d'andersen le symbole de
copenhague
mais il ya surtout les jardins de tivoli
ouvert depuis 1843
c'est l'un des plus vieux parc
d'attraction en europe
avec 4 millions de visiteurs par an il
est le site touristique le plus couru de
la ville on y trouve une dizaine de
manèges mais aussi ce vieux théâtre de
pantomime etienne son frère et son père
ont des étoiles plein les yeux fascinés
par ce spectacle d'un autre siècle et le
soir venu
l'endroit devient vraiment magique
[Musique]
leur musique trop forte c'est en étude
et merveilles comme un gamin
comptez quand même 50 euros la balade
le lendemain direction un quartier qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs
christiania du nom d'un roi danois
kristian une bulle de liberté devenu une
attraction pour touristes
c'est un symbole de la liberté
christiania pour les jockeys à
copenhague
ouais moi c'est c'est ce à quoi s'est
donc ce de façon générale ils sont très
attachés à leur liberté est ici c'est un
peu un cran au dessus christiania c'est
une ville dans la ville située en plein
coeur de copenhague
à deux pas du centre ville et de ses
canaux franchir ses portes
c'est entré dans une autre dimension où
le temps défile au ralenti ici les
voitures et les bateaux sont interdits
on se déplace à pied ou à vélo
[Musique]
et au fil des allées on découvre des
bicoques de bric et de broc toutes plus
folles les unes que les autres
une française fait partie des premières
à s'être installés ici depuis 1976
elle habite dans cette maison à 24 ans
hélène quitte la france a tiré par le
nord de l'europe
arrivé ici elle n'a plus voulu partir me
comble et comblé mon besoin de de
liberté et libertés à différents niveaux
liberté personnelle liberté d'être celle
que je suis et puis ce côté un peu fou
que j'ai et qui est que tout le monde a
ici
[Musique]
christiania c'est l'histoire d'un
symbole de la guerre reconverti en
royaume de l'amour et de la paix en 1971
cette ancienne base militaire est
investi par des hippies des anarchistes
des intellectuels des artistes et des
étudiants
une communauté autogéré et démocratique
un laboratoire social
seulement trois lois régissent le
quotidien des 800 christianites pas de
violence pas d'armes et pas de drogue
dure pendant 40 ans le gouvernement a
tenté à plusieurs reprises d'exclure les
indésirables et de reprendre possession
des lieux
en vain hélène et ses amis christianites
ont toujours résisté
c'était les années 70 et qui avait cette
extrême liberté et douceur dans l'air
aussi chez les politiciens
et donc après c'était pratiquement
impossible de nous mettre à la porte là
on est combien on a quatre ou cinq
générations
on a nos petits et puis des gens qui ont
80 ans pour garder l'originalité des
lieux le gouvernement a interdit toute
nouvelle construction à christiania rien
ne s'achète à rien ne se perd mais tous
échangent donc ici c'est un endroit où
on met ce qu'on ne veut plus avoir dans
sa maison et puis tout le monde peut
prendre quelques ce qu'ils veulent
gratuit si vous voulez savoir tout ce
que je porte sur moi je les trouvais ici
des vêtements des livres et des jouets
pour les enfants n'attend qu'un peu tout
trouvé ici même des bijoux
hélène la française de christiania est
bien connue de tous les habitants de
dispensaires c'est là que j'ai travaillé
le plus longtemps
elle ya travaillé pendant 12 ans chaque
jour elle devait soigner les corps et
les coeurs dans ce reportage tourné il
ya 20 ans on la voit au travail dans ce
même dispensaire évident
très difficile mais bon intéressante une
certaine façon oui pourquoi c'est très
difficile parce qu'il ya beaucoup de cas
sociaux estime que c'est noir vingt ans
après le dispensaire recevoir une fois
par semaine la visite d'un médecin
mais les plantes et la médecine
alternative reste ici la priorité c est
fantastique les herbes et on fait des
mélanges d'herbes pour pour être heures
pour faire l'amour pur
pour la beauté pour se relaxer un thé
pour tous les jours on fait des mélanges
à christiania on aime aussi consommer
une autre plante
celle qui fait planer o'neal a member et
consommateurs se cachent ils ne veulent
pas être filmés sur la place de
l'épicerie hélène retrouve régulièrement
ses amis de 40 ans il savoure temps
semble la chance de faire partie de
cette communauté à part du monde est
beau et gentil ici c'est comme ça elle
est suédoise et elle vit ici depuis 40
ans 40 ans ça fait longtemps mais je
n'ai pas réussi à trouver le chemin du
retour il y avait trop de fumée alors
sur esprit la folie la singularité et le
côté anarchiste de ce quartier de la
capitale danoise continue de faire débat
mais christiania mais pour le moment pas
près de disparaître son atmosphère
libertaire souffre le même aujourd'hui à
copenhague
c'est le premier jour de distorsion le
festival de musique organisé par thomas
et ça se passe de l'autre côté de ce
pont
alors là on en est à l'entraîneur bros
c'est le pigalle oberkampf 2
de copenhague ça c'est le vrai
distorsion avec une quarantaine de cm et
d'effets de quartier a dans tous les
coins il n'est que ces heures la fête ne
fait que démarrer et l'esprit est plutôt
bon enfant des étudiants des familles
les des fêtards se côtoient dans une
ambiance qui ressemblerait presque à
notre bonne vieille fête de la musique
en version électro
et dire que thomas a démarré ce festival
il y a vingt ans de manière totalement
illégale
à l'époque il était journaliste culturel
dans un quotidien local
ils organisent une fête dans des lieux
alternatifs sans aucune autorisation et
se fait vite débordé par les événements
c'était dans une toute petite à boutique
larmes dans cette rue là et un région
300 personnes hors de la boutique
la police est venue ils ont vu la fête
ils sont dix ans a l'air sympa ils ont
pris la plume héros mobile ils ont dit
écoute les gars vous faites votre aide
jusqu'à minuit pour moi pmi lui pour
vous confirmer que c'est fermé
on leur a dit ok entre temps ils ont
fait la sécurité ils ont bloqué le
trafic pour nous avec deux voitures de
patrouille on a fermé un menu et et
c'est là que 50 en france
la police aurait sans doute interrompu
la fête et l'histoire se serait arrêtée
là
mais nous sommes au danemark thomas en
constatant l'ouverture des autorités y
voit une opportunité qu'il instaure un
dialogue avec la mairie la fête plutôt
sauvage à ses débuts devient officiel et
prend très vite de l'ampleur avec
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux
l'année d'après pour la première fois en
2000 personnes dans la rue
hop on était là mille personnes n'est
pas possible en 2007 et 2012 on était
150 me
cent cinquante mille personnes dans les
rues et une jeunesse danoise qui exulte
et profite des premiers rayons de soleil
de l'été chaque année le festival est
devenu une institution dans le pays
pour se déplacer thomas a opté pour ceux
d en bus la theurre et il ne peut pas
faire sans mettre sans se faire alpaguer
par an le fan reconnaissance c'est
vraiment unique ce que tu as créé qui
fédère tout le danemark quelle que soit
la couleur de peau la religion c'est du
pur amour jusqu'à minuit le patron va
passer de san en scène pour s'assurer du
bon déroulement de la fête
[Musique]
il en profite même pour esquisser
quelques pas de danse
et s'il a le sourire c'est qu'il est
plutôt confiant en vingt ans de festival
bien que l'alcool coule à flots dauman a
dû gérer qu'un seul drame
la fois où un policier s'est pris un
coup de couteau par un déséquilibré son
vrai combat ce n'est pas la violence
mais plutôt ce type de débordements
[Musique]
alors thomas a essayé de déployer des
astuces pour lutter contre les
incivilités des fêtards comme ces
pancartes collées sur les murs parce
qu'il écrit cette piste dans une grille
est célébré comme ça il y en a partout
en tout copenhague
donc c'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
essayer de protéger les habitantes
il ya aussi ces urinoirs en plastique
improbable bricoler avec des tuyaux
d'arrosage cet incivisme au pays de la
bière
cela commence à agacer certains
riverains sur le pont qui mène à la fête
thomas est invité par la tv danoise pour
débattre en direct avec une habitante du
quartier
plutôt remonté écoutez il y en a marre
on a trop de problème on a tellement de
choses à faire on doit mettre des
barrières autour de notre résidence pour
éviter que les gens se soulagent devant
notre porte
c est bien là airlines est le seul
indice droite tôt
oui eh bien je suis obligé de réagir car
le manuel de l'habitant je les regarde
et je pensais que c'était une blague
vous dites par exemple aller chez
toys'r'us et vous dit le mot de passe
distorsion on vous donnait alors un
pistolet à eau et donc je peux arroser
les habitants qui font pipi devant mon
porsche mais vous dites aussi à
attention de les arroser pas trop pour
ne pas provoquer de bagarre attendez
c'est quoi ces plaisanteries depuis la
création de l'événement
c'est la première fois que les riverains
manifestent leur mécontentement
de quoi menacer le festival pas vraiment
le rouge et or
moi je les comprends je comprends la
date en france on prend des gens puis sa
beauté naturelle et des lois l'esprit
des kings il y en a une qui s'est vite
adapté à l'esprit vikings allison ne
parle pas encore leur langue mais elle
est bien décidée à profiter du festival
jusqu'au bout de la nuit avec ses amis
députés
la plupart sont des étudiants étrangers
comme elle la tête à la fête est là
n'oublie de leur parler en anglais
alors pour mieux s'intégrer et se faire
des amis danois
si elle a pris une grande décision le
lendemain
copenhague a retrouvé sa tranquillité
dans les rues les vélos ont repris leurs
droits entre son master d'informatique
les son petit boulot au restaurant
allison se rend trois heures par semaine
à son cours de danois tu t'assois tués
dans le groupe 3 allison ce jour là dans
le groupe de discussion d'alison emma du
texas et classe des pays bas malgré leur
niveau avancé en danois ils ont souvent
du mal à se faire comprendre
[Musique]
kate est ni voir qu'est-ce qui est le
plus difficile quand tu apprends le
danois les plus difficiles tout est
difficile
il ya plusieurs lettres qui sont
vraiment difficiles à prononcer et donc
à mémoriser des
pas fort et donc la pression a
longuement compliqué à faire quand on
parle
et voilà des goûters magiques commandite
un os dans la classe tous sont étudiants
aux mères de famille et le cours est
gratuit
l'état prend tout en charge le danemark
est la meilleure qualité de vie au monde
est ce que vous êtes d'accord oui par
exemple il y a beaucoup moins de
criminalité dans la rue on va je pense
aussi aux femmes les femmes ont les
mêmes droits que les hommes le danemark
est l'un des pays au monde où il ya le
plus grand pourcentage de femmes qui
sont sur le marché du travail
ce sens de l'équité il dit à la
confiance en les danois les uns envers
les autres
sadate des vikings parce que les vikings
devait compter les uns sur les autres
quand il partait sur leur grand bain il
était très important que tout le monde
puisse se faire confiance il était en
mer pendant des semaines et des semaines
donc il fallait que la confiance règne
cet état d'esprit des premières tribus
de viking a perduré
le peuple est resté soudé et le
gouvernement fait en sorte que tous ses
concitoyens et les mêmes privilèges
tout le monde ici a droit au bonheur
comme se ressourcer dans la nature
ça fait partie intégrante de la culture
quitté la ville pour rejoindre les
campagnes où le board
c'est ce que fait la famille fleurquin
chaque fin de semaine comme la plupart
des danois thomas s'est acheté il ya
quelques années une maison au bord de
l'eau d'avoir la maison
ce luxe d'avoir une résidence secondaire
le gouvernement danois a voulu l'étendre
à toute la population
en créant un système de copropriété les
résidents paix 20000 euros pour adhérer
au programme puis une cotisation
d'environ 1000 euros par an des
associations qui achètent des terrains
en groupe en association et libourne des
petites cabines les petites maisonnettes
avec un jardin genre somaliens ont
séduit mais c'est super sympa de 4.2
système pour avoir des maisons de
campagne pour les gens qui sont
c'est bien
à rêver
thomas fait partie des privilégiés il a
dépensé toutes ses économies pour
s'offrir pour lui tout seul cette
splendide maison en bois avec cette vue
incroyable sur la mer là le paradis en
sorte de paradis c'est le bioshock
à peine arrivé eva a déjà enfilé son
maillot de bain ce les forts du week end
regonflé les plus des vélos et après
quelques coups de voilà des
kilomètres de plage déserte au poser sa
serviette et c'est fou c'est une heure
de copenhague et c'est pas du tout
populaires les maisons sont au prix bas
et la nature sait c'est parfait les 18
degrés de la mer baltique ne
refroidissent pas la petite eva anton
lui va passer son tour aujourd'hui
autrement dit les ressources d'un outil
au danemark
ah oui mais quand on voit qu'ils
viennent toute l'année thomas envisage
aujourd'hui d'exporter son festival de
musique un peu partout en europe mais il
n'a aucune intention de revenir
s'installer en france comme la plupart
des français qui vivent à copenhague et
lui est pour l'instant inenvisageable de
quitter un jour la capitale du bonheur